regarde nous avons jeté toute la
poubelle nous a rendu toutes les
poubelles nous sorties toutes les
stockies pas bon cela fait presque 10
ans que Jacquot vit dans les parages
sous ce pan de l'autoroute Ville-Marie
près du centre ville de Montréal il
vient d'y passer un nouvel hiver mais ce
qu'il redoute c'est le printemps
des transports veut faire place net à
très court terme dès que les conditions
météo vont s'améliorer le chantier va
reprendre le principal enjeu est un
enjeu de sécurité parce que on doit
effectuer des travaux sur les structures
et en dessous des structures et entre
autres sur certaines piles sur
lesquelles sont situées les tentes de
certains campeurs un premier
démantèlement prévu début novembre avait
été repoussé pour trouver des solutions
de relogement mais depuis les bonnes
nouvelles ont été rares
étaient ici et
le premier février dans un nouveau
appartement c'est bon mais il reste une
quinzaine de personnes sans solution le
SUS dit être intervenu à plusieurs
reprises et nous écrit les campeurs ont
le droit de refuser les services et le
fond souvent les campeurs ont été avisés
qu'ils doivent déménager si ce n'est pas
possible
OK
où elle est apparemment ici
mais pas question pour le ministère de
laisser le campement se déplacer sous
l'autoroute on va travailler sur
l'envoi de façon sécuritaire les
déménagements ont forcé sont toujours
désastreux selon la nouvelle défenseur
fédérale du logement
qui existe en ces personnes et encore
avec leur indépendant c'est que cette
protection est perdue et elle interpelle
tous les niveaux de gouvernement et
notamment le municipal ça serait de
travailler avec la Ville de Montréal
pour trouver des options même ce que ça
serait un autre site elle cite l'exemple
de crap Park à Vancouver ou le
gouvernement finance des services et des
sanitaires par exemple la ville de
Montréal maintient que les campements ne
sont pas une solution à ses yeux à la
mobiliser des agents sociaux
communautaires pour accompagner ces
personnes vers des ressources des
ressources qu'elles ont délibérément
choisies de ne pas fréquenter ici
Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal